你有沒有想過，如果有一天，有場比賽是獎勵你「變年輕」的？不是那種心理上的年輕喔，是真的生理數據上的年輕。
等等，這裡我有疑問。變年輕？這聽起來有點出乎意料，因為我們都知道時間是單向流動的，生理年齡怎麼可能倒退？這跟我們一般想法不同吧。
確實是這樣。這個創新案例來自「MIT科技評論」提到的一個競賽，叫做「Younger contest」。它正是反其道而行，獎勵那些在六個月內，讓自己生物年齡變年輕的參賽者。
生物年齡？所以不是看身分證上的歲數，是看身體實際狀況的數據？那具體是怎麼做的？總不會是隨便說說吧？
對，這個競賽的創辦人是神經科學家 Christin Glorioso，她同時也是 NeuroAge Therapeutics 的執行長。她想利用多種「老化時鐘」來測量生物年齡。
這些老化時鐘會測量 DNA 上的化學標誌、血液中的蛋白質、脂質，甚至還有臉部辨識軟體來判斷你的「臉齡」。參賽者大約有 500 人。
500 人，聽起來規模不小。不過，這些測量真的準嗎？我猜啦，現在市面上也有很多這類健康檢查，但感覺可信度有待觀察，更何況要以此作為競賽標準。
這點其實不容易做到。原文有提到，Glorioso 承認目前單一的老化時鐘還不夠準確，所以競賽會採用多種測量方式，結合血液樣本、認知任務、甚至握力等物理指標。
喔，所以是用多角度的數據來交叉驗證，想辦法讓結果更全面。那獎勵是什麼？只是變年輕這個「成就感」嗎？
獲勝者會是那些生物年齡和實際年齡差距最大的人，以及生物年齡逆轉最多的人。這其實不只是一個比賽，Glorioso 還有一個目標，就是要建立「世界上最全面的老化時鐘數據集」。
產生數據集，這我就懂了。所以這不只是為了參賽者，其實也是一個大型的科學實驗，想了解各種老化時鐘的有效性，以及不同的健康干預措施對生物年齡的影響？
沒錯。他們甚至會提供一些贊助商的低風險產品，像是紅光面膜、桑拿等等，來觀察這些東西對參與者生物年齡的影響。因為這些公司通常負擔不起獨立的臨床試驗。
這樣聽起來，這模式撐得久嗎？成本划算嗎？如果我是創業者，要從這裡學到什麼，才能應用到自己的生意上？不是每個產業都能做這種實驗吧。
我覺得，你可以從中學習的是「數據化遊樂化」和「反向激勵」。一般健身或健康管理都是獎勵你變瘦、變健康，這個競賽卻是獎勵你「變年輕」。
這點很有意思。可以把難以量化的健康目標，透過數據轉換成一個具體的、可競爭的指標。讓改善健康不再只是口號，而是像玩遊戲一樣有目標、有成就感。
嗯，所以是把「讓自己更好」的過程變得有趣。那對我們一般上班族來說，這個概念能怎麼帶入工作或生活？總不能每天測量自己的生物年齡吧。
我想到一件事，你可以把工作上比較枯燥、長期才看得到成效的任務，試著「數據化遊樂化」。比方說，學習新技能，不單只是學完，而是把它拆解成小目標。
像是你每天閱讀了多少頁書、完成多少題練習，然後用一個計分或進度條來呈現。當你達到某個里程碑，就給自己一個小獎勵。
這樣確實能提升參與感。把「枯燥的累積」變成「可視的進步」，而且還有「反向激勵」，就是說，如果目標是「變老」，那就要逆著去「變年輕」，這種出乎意料的設定，本身就很吸引人。
對，這個做法很有意思。把大家都覺得理所當然的「變老」或「時間流逝」，變成一個可以被挑戰、被逆轉的目標。好像也提醒了我們，很多看似不可逆的趨勢，其實都有重新定義的空間。